turkey has changed a lot since i visited
10 years ago for one the turkish lira is
significantly weaker so this delicious
turkish coffee that cost me roughly 4 us
dollars back in 2012 would have cost me
just 50 cents with today's conversion
rate and secondly when i was in istanbul
i didn't see a single crypto exchange i
mean back then people were just starting
to wrap their heads around what the
blockchain even was but today crypto
exchanges and ads can be seen all over
the city so why am i pointing these
things out because today inflation is
soaring in turkey it's much higher than
it is in other parts of the world
and many turks are piling into risky
cryptocurrencies
all of this is happening largely due to
recent government policies so i'm
heading into the office to learn more
about what's been going on in turkey and
how it could affect the broader global
economy let's go
so before we talk about crypto we have
to talk about inflation and why the
turkish lira fell so quickly see usually
central banks raise interest rates to
contain inflation and many countries
around the world have started to do that
but turkish president recep tayyip
erdogan has called high interest rates
the mother and father of all evil that's
a real quote from 2018.
not only has he demanded interest rate
cuts as part of an unorthodox strategy
to drive growth but he's fired nearly
every senior turkish official who
opposes his vision
so check this out
you'll see that as turkey's central bank
cut its key policy rate in the fall the
value of the turkish lira plunged
now many turks are struggling to buy
food fuel and other essentials protests
have broken out in the streets and some
citizens have called on erdogan to
resign
so far erdogan has shown no signs of
reversing course and he has maintained
that cutting rates will boost growth
and that is where crypto comes
in turks have been piling into
cryptocurrencies to escape the plunging
lira even though many of those
cryptocurrencies are just as volatile
and get this they're investing in crypto
despite the fact that turkey banned
crypto as a form of payment last year
and even though erdogan has signaled
more regulations are coming the turkish
era has been volatile
than bitcoin and the other coins
and
so we can invest in crypto bravely
addition to talking to a few turks i sat
down with my colleague caitlin ostroff
virtually since she's been reporting on
the trend i think there's a little bit
of a feeling that you know crypto is
even though it might have massive price
fluctuations
is here to stay and even when it's
fallen there's always been a level of
support that it's found
caitlin says in past downturns turks
have moved their money into dollars
euros and gold and many are still doing
that today
but the turkish government has tried for
years to get people to move their bank
deposits back to lira and lately it's
been ramping up those efforts so
what some people fear is that if the
government is not successful in that
they may resort to more draconian
measures of getting people out of
dollars and euros that's so interesting
so it's
a lot of this is just driven by distrust
yeah there's there's massive distrust
and that helps explain why many turks
are also turning to stable coins like
tether these are cryptocurrencies whose
value is pegged to traditional
currencies like the dollar as this data
from crypto compare shows us turks
increasingly move their money into
tether as both rates and the value of
the lira fell if this trend continues if
more and more turks move their money
into cryptocurrencies and exit the
turkish financial system altogether what
could that mean for the country
i mean it would be really destabilizing
and would probably lead to capital
controls so that's kind of the thing
that
everyone's been watching and frankly
waiting for to happen in turkey at some
point
so what does all of this mean for the
broader global economy well turkey's
central bank has signaled that it's done
cutting rates for now and the government
announced a rescue plan to encourage
people to hold the lira but analysts
still expect inflation to continue to
rise and the value of the lira to remain
under pressure and some fear that
further turmoil in turkey could have
bigger economic and geopolitical
implications some of the concern is that
if turkey goes into an economic tailspin
who are they going to get funding and
aid from and that's a little bit up in
the air
to the u.s and the west turkey is seen
as a critical economic partner nato
member and geopolitical ally in the
middle east
so if turkey turned to a country like
russia or china for economic aid it
would rattle nations around the world
so finally what does this mean for the
broader crypto community the fact that
turks are moving their money into
cryptocurrencies is unlikely to trigger
big price moves in them but if erdogan
responds by cracking down on crypto it
could potentially weigh on the value of
bitcoin and other digital assets at
least temporarily so i'd love to hear
from you what do you think is the best
way to protect yourself from inflation
and depreciation in other words what
would you do if you were in turkey leave
me a comment below and if you learned
something from this video be sure to
subscribe to the channel for more
stories like this one i'll see you next
time